質問コーナー twitter 場所です
はい減るお待たせいたしましたまず twitter のたくさんのご応募しつの
リクエストありがとうございますめっちゃ多かった
なんでごとに時間がかかったというちょっと言い訳をさせておくれ twitter の
質問とリクエスの量がとっても多かったですありがたいことに全部見ました
マジで本当に全部見ると夜に彼質問を探してたらこう
グラフ全部見ると気づいたらも朝になっててちょっとミスっだなと思ってますよね
ほんとにびっくりする女時間語ったのでちょっと今度からちょっと出るけどはた変え
なきゃなと思っておりますと言うと本当に楽しいもありがとうございますでは
twitter の質もこないってみましょうよ
右て容易に上げて
ん
左というふうに上げてその両方を頭上に持ってきて
睦博だよわぁ
何なんですかねこっちがのテーブルの連打とベンチの状態のも勉強しないと経験者を
積極ならあなたはプロしてください終わらな
勉強し0とダメだぞ
郡上むず johnbull 女っていつも議論ぷよいい精神科病院
お世話へいシンガー病院教えますよ俺もをの前久しぶりにシュルってみてたら誰か似
てるなぁって怒ってた
誰だろうあっ羽田は幽霊種
はじめを召喚貼っねーしてねーよいま留年しないために頑張ってます残念だから質問は
ない
ん
んやるぞ
今のところハズレアミューズメントパークの来場者は何人ですか全体動画で僕が思って
からまだ一人も来てませんありがとうございますおくんちで監視カメラをつけ良い
きっかけになった男の方から最近なんか手紙が届いてましてがちですよ本当に
もう1回でも来たんでしょ手紙が入ってましてちょっと読んでみようと思います始め
社長へすいませんぶかなり前監視カメラを付けるという動画を見ました行ったのは僕の
友達ですとしてこの手紙を書いたのは
あまりたかったらですすいませんでしたもしよろしければ苦境の動画で出してください
セカンドチャンネルでもいいのでそしてもし肇社長じゃなかったらすいません
サインください多い反省してねえだろ面白く逆再生やってください
[音楽]
[拍手]
たし商品も主未熟だしつまらない人から選ばれるわけないんです
イース選ばれなくてもわかってますからそんなことこのツイートを見てくれるだけでも
嬉しいんです
初めての動画を見れるだけでも嬉しいんですそれだけていけるか気になりますそんな
ことないですよ
見てくれてありがとうございますあの今回のその twitter の質問見てると
かなりこういう形が多かったです何かどうで選ばれないし
ビット版これ使ってとかそれはねちょっと違うと思うねそれ質問自体とかでゲットし
たいじゃなくて設問今に使われたりとかでペットとして使われたいって言う
こうなんかちょっと違うんですよねぜひねまどほ息があったらちゃんとした
鈴本ができるとお待ちしておりますちゃんと見てるよ余計る jk の鐘綾部綾部
良い策を死んじゃういい成功しなーい
テンションを上げ棒天童丸待って加奈子あんた待つとカレシの水かぶりよ
福地の対処は結構で天と地のキャンピングあるよね年のキャンピングまたそれを見た
遠い世あげぽゆ長部
ためしかねえ飯も白したりし5マーク人のマックフルーリー
除いていく結構言えるかなかきくけ校
yeah
me
舐めての何か質問しようとしたけど特に気になっていうことはなかった
段ボールを使って3秒クッキングをしてくださいまずはなポート世代するしてそのまま
口に運ぶ場所
子役の真似をしてなぁ
いやだ
んお父さんとハナへ
ない
んって
ああああああ
ni
ないいんああ
[音楽]
なんて質問してくれた最高の英語でくしゃみしてみてえーっ
体調悪くなったまず美貌を長期みてください1スピリー
ボランティア場所でえっ
質問1強くごとに服を一枚上でくださいから所沢にズってくれませんか
だめだ所沢俺の家族なんだ別に質問じゃないけど初めのどうも前のほうが良かったと
言ってる人よく居るけどわしは居間のが好き
雪っううありがとうございます六ヶ所行くかえでも僕にはどうすることも出来ません
菓子の動画がいいなと私が昔の動画を観ればいいし今はいいと面白い
の動画で見てくれればいいと思ってはつ変わらないものなんてないんだぜ
身長何センチですか1805cm
朝起きたら美女に囲まれていた時の反応
ああ
うぉっええっオーバーってはいけないで全然に8月のさんの多い由希
わー woman ちゃんの真似して最後に鼻からコーラ飲んでくださいポニーちゃん
とって冷凍かーっ
[音楽]
このコーナー6着漁よな簡単なシェアしてたんで飲みながら全然してください
汚くシュークリーム食べてみて背景に彼が来て者が質問コーナー本当にたくさんぞね
質問とかでクエストいただき本当にありがとうございます一応これで今回は終わりなん
ですけどもうまたねっ架空場所をちゃんと準備すべてまたそこにネット方は帰って
くださいね
ちゃんと全部読んでるからそれだけは注意してくださいですかな
[音楽]
うん